this is his first appearance
of 2020 and it comes at a time when the
twins
are struggling right now to score runs
and win ball games
rick randaria has just the opposite
situation they're scoring a lot of runs
they're winning a lot of ball games and
getting big hits
late on the ground pass first pineda's
got to get there tim's going to beat him
easily
and the sox take advantage of pineda's
speed
with tim's better speed for some reason
during the course of his career
he has not seen pineda very well
as jose rips this into left field that's
a base hit
and the sox have two on with one out in
the first
and here is eloy jimenez who is trying
to snap an over 13 skid over the last
four games
elloy to left field on a line up the
alleyway
rosario didn't see it well sox get one
here comes jose
sprinting for the plate he is saved
two-run double eloy jimenez and the sox
continue to give a reason
for you to be here at first pitch every
night what a beautiful swing by eloy
jimenez
no chance rosario could do anything as
abraya was picking him up
putting him down on the way to home
dallas keiko
on the hill looking for win number six a
zra at 270.
this is eighth start as you can see not
gonna strike out a lot of people he's
not gonna walk a lot of people
in the battle of the beards here with
dallas kikel and marwyn gonzalez and
that one's flared into right field
pretty well hit actually and now the
right fielder mazara will square up to
the home plate area and make that
catch and the inning has come to an end
no runs anderson
singled and scored in the first inning
now one for five in this series
out of the o2 pitch one more time and
that's cued into right field there's a
base hit for tim
anderson he just reached out and poked
that one into right field
and anderson has himself a couple of
singles in the game lead man aboard here
in the third two nothing white sox he's
finding ways to still get his hits
he's in full protection mode he
literally hits it off the very
end of the bat michael 31 pitches in his
first two innings just one hit allowed
to rosario he's been tough in all his
outings but he's been particularly tough
in the first five innings of his outings
he's only given up three runs
in the first five innings of all his
starts
jorge polacco will come up polanco
swings and pulls a line drive bases to
left near the corner
and then as was playing polanco to pull
so it's a long
single on the hardest hit ball the twins
have put into play tonight polanco
here is marwyn gonzalez who flied to
right field and the first inning
three balls one strike on gonzalez
and he grounds that one on the left side
it will be fielded by omar sanchez the
second for the force
and indeed it was the change up away
barney gilner bert bleilovan and dick
ramer here
twins trying to get something done
against dallas kykel
and so abreu with a diving stop to his
right
and they make the play rosario has a hit
taken away
on a great play by jose abrams yeah very
nice play dove to us right
we talked about what jose does well and
apparently he rolls around
and steals base hits because that's
exactly what happened
and rosario who got a base hit the first
time has a big smile on his face only
because
he can't kill jose because he's smaller
than he is he just had to throw it over
the base and dallas was there but jose
to his right a dive tumble and roll as
jose abreu will stride to the plate with
the bases loaded here's the pitch
number off the end of the bat first base
be fielded by ceno he'll take it himself
and steps on the bag and retires abreu
first bit swing and they leave him
loaded
and now gonzalez who lined out to right
in the first and then hit a ground ball
to sanchez to end the threat in the
third
tapper left side a run will score they
get the force at
second and the ball dropped at first or
it would not have scored the run
white sacks nearly turned a very
difficult double play that would have
kept falanco from scoring
but abreu dropped the ball i think the
first base umpire was ready to ring him
up too
took a big run doesn't it that the twins
were able to get
and we'll see whether it matters at all
deep drive left center field buckston
to the wall leaping and he caught it
buxton i think caught the ball they're
calling him out on the exchange
buxton climbs the wall to take an extra
base hit
away from encarnacion it's going to be
luisa rise
grabbing a bat for the catcher
a fair ball down the line cave scores to
tie the game
arise digging for second here's mazara's
throw
not in time and the twins used their
bench
to tie the game up here on the sixth the
player got a change up
and light it right down that first base
line ryu playing a bit off the line gets
by him
that'll bring up buckston driven down
the line a base hit
bruce to third base coming around he's
going to score
and buxton puts the twins in front with
a live drive
single to left
great stop at third adrianza comes up
firing
and sono digs it out what a play by
andreanza to start
the top of the night the opener closes
it down
matt whistler steps up big time to end
the six-game losing streak